it's like you snorted Joy I had such a
great time anytime we walked on that set
it was just kind of a magic experience
everything I've ever wanted is right
here and this
Place hey I'm Betty Gilpin and this is
set Diaries
we shot this show on the Warner Brothers
lot super cool uh in Los Angeles and in
and around La as an old Hollywood fan I
kept picturing Betty Davis you know
walking around smoking it was just all
very surreal so I had to like walk
around to like pinch myself and you know
really really take it all in we also
shot the show in Spain which was amazing
in and around Barcelona to double for
Scotland to double for Italy it's nice
to see you
typical day consisted of me bringing my
guitar to work and playing guitar
outside of my trailer and that was uh
how I sort of got into my day it arrived
to set the genius Lana horachowski would
do my makeup the genius Theresa Rivers
would do my hair I'd get in my habit
with the Catherine Hepburn pant I'd put
on the wimple and I would waddle to set
you know be greeted by whatever
brilliant actor I was working with that
day and we'd proceed to be absolutely
ridiculous
your [__] minds hey Mom majority of
my time I was with Betty in fact it was
really jarring uh the first time I saw
Betty out of a nun habit good to see you
out of your numb costume it's not a
costume that's who I am this is the
first time that Betty and I have worked
together and I will work with her until
the end of time wherever you go
I will be there also grateful that my
introduction to Betty's work was on set
on Mrs Davis otherwise I would have been
horribly intimidated she's such a
brilliant comedian and such a deep
dramatic actor feeling many things right
that it was an absolute Joy
I had the hardest laughs of my life on
this set okay I I recruited particularly
with Jake McDormand we're both July 86th
so we've got we've got that Bond I
didn't even bother wrapping her presents
this one Peaks you always gave me
terrible presents
hate everything
what do you yeah yours stop it
so hard I mean it made this shoot day
longer sometimes because a lot of times
we're supposed to be very serious we had
a lot of fun I mean especially when we
got
all the characters together as we got
like deeper in and we got to throw you
know Beth Marvel and I'm going with You
Chris diamantopoulos do not flatter me
happy best part of set was getting into
the Falafel and getting into these
scenes and the worst part was leaving it
all behind I'm gonna go say goodbye now
biggest challenge was coming to terms
with the fact that it wasn't going to
last forever we were just all so
obsessed with the show and so obsessed
with each other when we wrapped in Spain
I sat in the terminal of the Barcelona
Airport and had snot and tears pouring
down my face like
I know it's boring to have an actor just
tell you everything was great everybody
had a great time but unfortunately for
you it's true this time and there wasn't
a worse part sorry
from set to screen it's now time to
stream head on over to Peacock to watch
Mrs Davis
foreign